Dieses extravagante, technisch zukunftsweisende Endprodukt jahrzehntelanger Grundlagenforschung in deiner Hand, alle Achtung! Die Industrie-Spioner dieser Welt werden dich gnadenlos jagen!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nummer 63. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ihr hört den Podcast, wo es immer um irgendwelche Sachen geht. Und heute geht es um eine ganz tolle Sache. Heute geht es nämlich um Programmiersprachen. Jaha, werdet ihr sagen, hatten wir ja schon mal. Und da kommt auch schon der Gast dazwischen. Also jetzt hast du dich jetzt schon verraten.
Es geht um eine Programmiersprache.
Jetzt hast du dich schon verraten. Ich begrüße Pavel. Hallo, Pavel.
Hallo, Tim.
Um zu reden über ein Thema, was wir jetzt schon seit wie vielen Monaten vor uns her schieben, ich glaube seit fast 90. Nein, ich meine nicht das Thema als solches, sondern das Thema für diesen Podcast.
Das Thema für diesen Podcast haben wir schon ganz am Anfang, vor Jahren, also vor Jahren wollten wir schon einen C++ Podcast machen.
Du meinst jetzt für Chaosradio? Ja, echt?
Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, das war ein ganz, ganz langes Thema schon und wir haben ein paar andere vorgezogen, weil das einfach so ein schwieriges Thema war und weil das auch ein ganz ernstes Thema ist, was mir so sehr am Herzen liegt, dass ich erst ein paar Podcasts irgendwie vorgezogen habe, um dann wirklich dieses eine wichtige Lebensthema C++...
Jetzt hätte ich noch so eine Tasse mit Köhren irgendwie einbauen sollen, aber wir haben euch jetzt nicht darauf vorbereitet. Na ja, wie auch immer, ihr merkt schon, heute geht es mal wieder ums Ganze und wir haben uns ein kerniges Thema vorgenommen, nämlich C++, die Programmiersprache. Wir haben hier schon so einiges durchgekaut, vielleicht für die Leute, die dich jetzt noch nicht gehört haben, hier bei Chaosradio Express. Ich weiß gar nicht, was hatten wir zuletzt? Zuletzt hatten wir unser Gespräch über Sicherheit und wir haben uns auch schon mal sehr schön über Extreme Programming unterhalten, wo du ja schon klar geworden bist, du bist ja seit langer Zeit auch in der Entwicklung tätig. Das heißt, Programmierung ist für dich nichts Neues. Seit wann entwickelst du für Computer?
So seit 1980 etwa. Das sind jetzt gut 27 Jahre wahrscheinlich, als ich angefangen habe und davor habe ich dann Elektronik aneinander gelötet. Also im zarten Alter von 12 Jahren habe ich das nicht begonnen.
Also bist du eigentlich auch noch ein totaler Oldschooler. Du kennst es noch, Computer ohne Hochsprachen zu programmieren und ohne geschweifte Klammern, sprich in rohen Prozessorcode in December.
Ja, Maschinensprache.
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch so die Zeit, wo diese Programmiersprache herkommt, also teils, teils.
Ja, doch.
Beziehungsweise, wo die Vorläufer kommen.
1979 hat der Vorläufer namens C with Classes, ja.
Wann war das?
1979, C with Classes.
Ach echt?
Ja, schon. Und der Name C++ ist das erste Mal 1983, also verwendet worden. Da gab es halt die erste Implementierung und einen Nutzer von C++. Einen, ja.
Einen Entwickler?
Ja, Bjarne Strohstrup. Und so richtig ging das dann. Also 1985 ging das dann halt so mit Seafront 1.0 los. Das war dann aber sicherlich so in akademischen Kreisen. Und eigentlich Anfang der 90er. So ging der Boom. Also 1990 erschien auch das Annotated Reference Manual, auch genannt ARM. Und es liest sich auch wie eine Waffe. Also es ist ein hartes Stück Literatur.
Es liest sich wie eine Waffe.
Ja, also es ist ein ziemlich brutales Werk. Also es ist nichts für zarte Gemüter.
Aber in dem Ruf steht ja nun C++ auch generell, oder?
Ja, also C++ gehört zu den meistgehassten Programmiersprachen auf der Welt. Zu Recht? Na ja, also sagen wir mal so, wenn auf der Welt nur eine einzige Programmiersprache erlaubt wäre. Wenn aus irgendwelchen Gründen man sich für eine Programmiersprache entscheiden müsste. Und alle anderen wären verboten oder aus der Reichweite. Denn glaube ich, wäre doch C++ der Kandidat, der einfach die besten Aussichten hätte, als die einzige Programmiersprache der Welt, das größte Spektrum abzudecken von allen existierenden Programmiersprachen.
Gut, ich würde jetzt ganz gerne erstmal noch ein bisschen zurückspulen. C++ hat ja schon im Namen dieses Meme Ich bin C, bloß ein Schritt weiter. Das heißt, dass C++ eigentlich C ist, plus ein bisschen Objektgarnitur obendrauf. Ich denke, das ist eine sehr populäre Sicht auf diese Programmiersprache. Oder gibt es schon irgendetwas wirklich Eigenständiges?
Es ist schon etwas ganz anderes, würde ich sagen. Es ist so, dass allerdings ganz bewusst damals die Entscheidung getroffen wurde, C als Basis, als Subset zu nehmen, als Ausgangspunkt, und auch quasi eine Kompatibilität zu haben. Das heißt, lange Jahre war es so, dass man praktisch auch C-Code durch jeden C-Compiler schicken konnte. Beziehungsweise die ersten C++-Implementierungen waren einfach Compiler oder Präprozessoren, die einfach C-Code erzeugt haben.
Das ist das von dir schon erwähnte C-Front.
Ja, genau. Das waren die ersten Implementierungen.
Das waren eigentlich nur C++-Tocetranslatoren.
Ja, Präprozessoren tatsächlich. Und von daher ist C eine Basis. Aber im Laufe der Jahre ist es so, dass C++ wesentlich mehr Hirnschmalz reingesteckt wurde. Weil C ist an irgendeinem Punkt als Programmiersprache doch sehr, sehr einfach. Als Gegenstand auch intellektueller Auseinandersetzung. Da ist C halt wenig dran. Und das führte dann auch dazu, dass irgendwann C begonnen hat. Also die Standardisierung von C. Wiederum Features, die zuerst in C++ aufgetaucht sind und standardisiert sind, dann in den C-Standard zu übernehmen, weil man gesehen hat, es ist... Berne sagt immer, C++ ist eigentlich das bessere C. Und dem kann man sich eigentlich nur anschließen.
Also, um es gleich noch mal hier auch deutlich zu sagen, wir wollen jetzt hier keine... Wir wollen jetzt hier nicht das Referenzmanual durchtigern. Und wir wollen auch nicht einen totalen... Wie soll ich es sagen? Also, das soll jetzt hier kein Tutorial in die Erlernung der Programmiersprache C++ sein. Sondern wir wollen versuchen, ein bisschen dem Wesen der Programmiersprache auf den Grund zu kommen. Ob uns das gedingt, das werden wir dann ja sehen. Aber du hast ja eine ganze Menge Gedanken gemacht über das Design der Programmiersprache C++. Und ich meine, ich nehme auch gerne hier die Position ein, die ich eigentlich auch sonst vertrete, damit das C++-Programme vor allem abstürzen. Das ist so meine Erfahrung eigentlich mit C++-Software. Sie hat vor allem immer so die Eigenschaft abzustürzen. Und von daher kann ich deine Begeisterung nur sehr eingeschränkt teilen. Aber jetzt ist es ja so, dass du ja auch selber größere Projekte durchführst mit C++, mit einem größeren Team. Wo wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen haben, habe ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt, wie viele Leute, wie groß ist da die Herde, die du da gemeinsam an einem Projekt wirken hast.
Also insgesamt die an einem Stück Software arbeiten, die Leute gleichzeitig sind so etwa zehn Menschen zurzeit, wobei insgesamt auch natürlich Leute kommen und gehen. Das heißt, an dieser Software haben sich insgesamt eher so 20 bis 25 Menschen in den letzten Jahren dort ihre Beiträge geleistet. Das ist ein Projekt, das ist eine 3D-Engine und ein Multimedia-Framework, um das es geht. Also mit Echtzeitanforderungen, Computer, Grafik, Audio, Video, dieser ganzen Kram. Und es ist so ein mittelgroßes Projekt mit rund im Augenblick 400.000 Code-Zeilen. Es gibt deutlich größere Projekte. Windows 2000 liegt in einer Größenordnung von 10 Millionen Code-Zeilen. Es gibt große Software-Pakete, Software-Produkte, die Standard-Software-Produkte liegen bei 1 bis 2 Millionen Zeilen. Wenn man sich so ein Wort anguckt, wird sich das in dieser Größenordnung bewegen. Oder irgendeine größere 3D-Modeling-Software liegt im Bereich einiger Millionen. Es gibt also deutlich größere Projekte. Du sagtest zum Thema Abstürzen. Ist es schon so, C++ ermöglicht es dir auch, wenn du willst, kannst du dir auch grandios in den Fuß schießen. Bjarne Strußtrupp hat sogar mal gesagt, C++ stellt eine ganze Reihe Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung, um sich nicht in den Fuß zu schießen. Aber wenn man sich in den Fuß schießt, ist das ganze Bein weg. Da ist auch durchaus was Wahres dran. Aber es ist auch tatsächlich so, man kann mit C++ auch fehlerfreien, sicheren und bequemen Code schreiben.
Wenn man das richtige Zen drauf hat.
Wenn man weiß, was man tut. Ich habe vor Jahren festgestellt, ich habe so 1993, 1994 mit C++ begonnen, meine ersten C++ Programme zu schreiben. Nach einem Jahr dachte ich, wow, jetzt irgendwie kannst du C++. Nach einem weiteren Jahr habe ich mir die Programme angeguckt, die ich nach einem Jahr geschrieben habe und dachte, was hast du da denn für einen Mist gemacht? Jetzt kannst du C++. Zwei Jahre später dachte ich, okay, so langsam nach vier Jahren arbeiten, müsste ich es ja eigentlich so langsam drauf haben. Um aber immer wieder festzustellen, irgendwann wird mir klar, C++ hat eben was von so einer asiatischen Kampfsportart. Das heißt, man fängt an und legt sich eben so ein Gürtel nach dem anderen zu. Man lernt halt immer neue Griffe. Und irgendwann fühlt man sich auch relativ sicher, weiß, wie man sicher fällt. Und so richtig interessant wird es aber, fängt C++ anzuwerden, wenn man quasi den schwarzen Gürtel erworben hat und beginnt, sich die einzelnen Darne zuzulegen. Und den schwarzen Gürtel, wie ich sage, den schafft man so nach vier, fünf Jahren etwa. Beschäftigen oder arbeiten mit C++ ist man glaube ich so weit, dass man die Sprache so in seiner Tiefe und Breite durchmessen hat. Und dann fängt man halt an, dann hat man die Grundlage, um wirklich auch mit dieser Sprache dann in neue Dimensionen vorzustoßen und hat einfach dann das Gefühl, dass man in der Lage ist, alles, aber auch wirklich alles mit dieser Sprache machen zu können und auch noch alles so machen zu können, dass es halbwegs schön, effizient und einfach nur nett ist. Aber das ist C++. Also die Lernkurve ist vorhanden, sie ist steil, sie ist lang, aber der Lohn, den man dann bekommt, wenn man diese Lernkurve gemeistert hat, ist, dass man eine Programmiersprache hat, mit der man alles tun kann.
Das heißt, so ein bisschen das Gegenteil von, sagen wir mal, Javascript, wo man mit relativ geringen Lernaufwand schon sehr weit kommen kann?
Ich würde sagen, Javascript hat auch seine Tiefe. Javascript wird ja von manchen auch als Lisp mit C-Syntax bezeichnet, aber ich würde eher Java gegensetzen. Aber da denke ich, das Thema C++, Java, weiß ich nicht, ob wir das jetzt schon beleuchten sollten. Vielleicht, glaube ich, wäre es an der Zeit, mal so ein paar Dinge für diejenigen, die nicht so vertraut sind mit C++, über die wesentlichen Dinge und Sprachfeatures zu sagen.
Da wollte ich jetzt auch drauf kommen. Genau, das ist immer so ein bisschen die Frage, was kann man jetzt eigentlich voraussetzen. Aber ich denke, wir sind jetzt erstmal eigentlich jeder, man sollte jetzt vielleicht eine Vorstellung davon haben, wie man so gemeinhin in den frühen Zeiten programmiert hat. Das ist so dieses einfache prozedurale Programmieren, was man ja auch häufig schon in der Schule, mittlerweile zumindest, mitbekommt. So dieses Schritt für Schritt, Anweisung für Anweisung, bestimmte Sachen kann man sich in kleinen Subroutinen zusammenlegen. Das ist so eine Denke, die sehr weit verbreitet ist und die ja auch viele Leute relativ erfolgreich auch in irgendwelchen Programmiersprachen machen, die man relativ einfach auch von Sprache zu Sprache mitnehmen kann.
Ja, also klassisch, also wenn man vergleicht, sind genau die Dinge in C oder in Fortran oder auch wie man in Assembler programmiert hat. Man hat Fallunterscheidungen, man hat Schleifen, natürlich klar sequenzielle Abarbeitung von Anweisungen, man hat irgendwelche Variablen und wie du schon sagtest, man hat als wichtigstes Abstraktionsmittel, um Wiederholungen zu vermeiden, hat man Funktionen, in die man dann eben aufrufen kann, Subroutinen, die man nutzt. Das ist so, ich sag mal...
Das findet sich eigentlich in allen Poemiersprachen, außer einigen völlig absurden, die jetzt alles unbedingt komplett anders machen müssen.
Ja, also jedenfalls ist das so der Standard in, ich sag mal, prozeduralen, imperativen Sprachen, die halt Anweisungen verwenden.
Und ist denn nun C++ wirklich vollständig auf C basiert, oder wo nimmt C++ seine Inspiration her? Also was war sozusagen die Motivation für die Entstehung von C++? Das würde mich als erstes mal interessieren.
Okay, also die Motivation, dass, also, Bjarne Strustrup, der Erfinder von C++, hat da auch in einem Buch Design and Evolution of C++, was ich nur empfehlen kann, was sehr aufschlussreich ist, hat das da recht gut geschildert, was die Motivation war. Seine Situation war, dass er damals einen Simulator schreiben wollte, um ein verteiltes Rechnersystem zu simulieren. Also er hatte so ein Cluster von mehreren Rechnern, die Nachrichten miteinander verschicken. Das wollte er auf einem Computer simulieren. Und hat dann geguckt, okay, womit schreibe ich den Simulator? Und ist auf die Programmiersprache Simular gestoßen. Die damals in Oslo am Norwegian Computing Center entstanden ist. Und die hat er halt gewählt, weil Simular hat ihm gefallen, für Simulationen auch mit Möglichkeiten, Co-Routinen zu schreiben und eben auch Klassen und Objekte und Ableitungen, virtuelle Methoden, das gab es alles in Simular und Sicherheit hingesetzt. Und sein verteiltes Rechnersystem eben in Simular beschriebene. Garbage Collection gab es übrigens auch in Simular. Alles war ganz toll.
Auf was für Computern lief das? Von welcher Zeit reden wir jetzt?
Wir reden so von Anfang, Mitte der 70er Jahre. Und was war das, auf dem er das geschrieben hat? Das war ein paar Kilobyte Hauptspeicher. Damals liefen die Geräte mit ein paar Hundert Kilohertz Prozessortakt. Die Rechner waren also nicht schnell. Es gab einerseits noch die IBM-Mainframer-Fraktion, die mit monstermäßigen Assemblerbefehlen hantierten. Dann gab es noch die evangelistische Uniszene, die dann auch mit PDP 11 oder anderen Rechnern, die waren relativ klein, nicht besonders leistungsfähig. Das Problem, was er dann hatte, war, dass er dieses wunderschöne Programm geschrieben hat, das aber in Simula ist, aber einfach zu langsam lief. Und zwar so langsam, dass einfach das Projekt drohte zu scheitern, weil er einfach keine vernünftigen Ergebnisse in der brauchbaren Zeit in der Lage war zu produzieren. Und hat dann daraufhin das ganze System nochmal in BCPL, eine Programmiersprache, einen C-Vorläufer, nochmal neu implementiert. Er meinte, schrieb dazu, das sei ein Horror gewesen, aber es lief wenigstens ausreichend schnell. Und so hat er halt das Projekt gerettet. Aber danach blieb halt so das Ding. Okay, er konnte das Problem in Simula wunderschön formulieren. Es lief leider zu langsam und BCPL war schnell genug, aber einfach pain in the ass zu programmieren. Und das war so der Punkt, wo er sagte, eigentlich hätte ich doch gerne eine Programmiersprache, wo ich die Abstraktionsmöglichkeiten habe, die ich in Simula habe, aber das Laufzeitverhalten, was ich mit BCPL oder dann eben später, also BCPL wurde dann zu B und anschließend zu C weiterentwickelt. Ja, und das war die Motivation.
Das heißt, er hat im Prinzip auch von vornherein schon in BCPL programmiert. Eigentlich so mit diesem Anspruch, im Prinzip programmiere ich jetzt all die ganzen Features, die ich bei Simula einfach benutzt habe. Die programmiere ich mir jetzt nochmal nach. Da wird also wahrscheinlich, vermute ich jetzt, sich ohnehin erstmal hier und da ein Framework gebaut haben, was diese Grundfeatures, Spracheigenschaften von Simula simuliert, weil er ja in der Denke schon an die Sache herangegangen ist. Und damit hat er im Prinzip schon mal einen groben Entwurf seiner Programmiersprache.
Ja, bei BCPL war das Ding wie man auch, wer das erste Königin Richie C kennt, da gibt es ja auch nur sehr wenig. Ich meine, da gab es schon ein einfaches Typensystem, aber in BCPL gab es im Prinzip überhaupt gar keine Typen. Das heißt, man hatte halt in BCPL nur Maschinenworte. Und je nachdem, wie man sie verwendete, so dieses Stück, was für Operatoren man drauf anwendete, war es entweder ein Pointer oder eine Fließkommazahl oder eine Integerzahl oder eine Sprungadresse oder was auch immer. Und das führte natürlich dazu, dass der Compiler sehr einfach war. Also es hatte irgendwie, das ist wohl Compiler, BCPL-Compiler gehabt, die irgendwie in ein Kilobyte-Code hineingepasst haben. Aber natürlich, der Compiler hat alles durchgehen lassen und beim Debuggen wurde es dann halt das Problem, dass einem alles um die Ohren flog.
Das heißt, dann hat er jetzt dieses Projekt gemacht und es ist ihm dann sozusagen in dem Moment dann aufgekommen, oh Mann, jetzt mache ich gleich eine ganz premiere Sprache draus. Also es war dann sozusagen gleich sein nächstes Projekt?
Sein nächstes Projekt, ja, weiß ich.
Also jetzt nicht so wichtig, ob es für dich sein nächstes Projekt war, aber im Prinzip hat er dann begonnen, C++ zu entwerfen, was erstmal nicht so hieß vielleicht, sondern was...
Also erstmal für sich, erstmal hat er das für sich gemacht und auch vielleicht auch noch ein sehr nettes Zitat von ihm, wo er sagte, er hat C++ nicht geschrieben, um irgendwie etwas zu beweisen, sondern um ein Problem zu lösen. Also original, das glaube ich, I wrote C++ not to prove a point, but to solve a problem. So und auch die weitere Entwicklung, die Evolution anschließend von C++, das müssen wir auch sehen. C++ hat eine sehr, sehr lange Evolution hinter sich. Da hat sich nicht jemand hingesetzt am grünen Tisch und gesagt, das ist es jetzt, sondern C++ hat 15 Jahre bis zur Reife gebraucht. Das ist eine Programmiersprache, also bis zum Standard. Ich meine sogar länger. 1998, muss man sich überlegen, wurde tatsächlich der erste C++-Standard verabschiedet. Das heißt, 19 Jahre hat es gedauert, vom Anfang bis zur Standardisierung von C++. Das heißt, es ist auch ein sehr gereiftes System. Gut, was ist vielleicht jetzt die Frage? Was ist C with Classes war halt. Das Thema. C++ war das erste, was einem dann auffiel an C++, war das Thema objektorientierte Programmierung, was auch in den 90ern seinen Ausgangspunkt kam. Das heißt, C++ stand halt ganz prominent auch für das Thema objektorientierte Programmierung, obwohl es andere Systeme gab, die eher rein objektorientiert waren. Aber für den normalen Programmierer war, oder für viele normale Programmierer, die jetzt nicht im akademischen Umfeld. Oder auf der Seite von Smalltalk oder anderen unterwegs waren, war das der erste Kontakt mit Objekten. Pascal hat sich dann ja auch in Form von Object Pascal auf eine objektorientierte Variante dann zugelegt. Der entscheidende Punkt war jetzt mit den Objekten und Klassen, dass man im Gegensatz zu der prozeduralen Programmierung auf die Idee kam, wir machen Objekte und Objekte sind Sammlungen von Funktionen und Daten, die quasi irgendwo gekapselt sind. Das war so die Grundidee. Während vorher lagen dort die Daten und dort war das Programm und irgendwie ließ man dann das Programm auf sämtliche Daten los. Das Programm war in der Lage, in alle Daten hineinzugreifen, die es gab und in dem Moment, wo man plötzlich Objekte hatte, konnte man Programme schreiben, die nur auf eine Untermenge von Daten zugreifen konnten und damit konnte man dafür sorgen, dass so ein Programm einfach modularer aufgebaut war, dass gerade bei komplexeren Programmen nicht so ein Haufen Spaghetti entstand, wo jede Funktion überall unterwegs war, sondern man hat es eben besser sortiert. Und dann kam eben noch ein weiterer Punkt bei den Objekten hinzu, nämlich das Thema Klassen und das Thema Ableitung, Klassenhierarchien, wo man eben Gemeinsamkeiten bestimmter Objekte in einer Basis-Klasse implementieren konnte und die Unterschiede dann eben in abgeleiteten Klassen.
War das auch schon eine Idee, die in Simula drin war?
Ja.
Das heißt, kann man sagen, dass Simula eigentlich so ein bisschen die Mutter aller objektorientierten Poemiersprachen ist? Das ist ja auch so weit vor Smalltalk gewesen.
Ja, ich glaube, das passierte meines Wissens in etwa parallel. Aber Simula ist definitiv der Vorläufer von, kann man sagen, C++, Java und C-Sharp sind eigentlich massiv von Simula letztendlich inspiriert. Also die Art und Weise auch Objekte und Klassen, also wie wir sie zumindest in diesen Programmiersprachen kennen, die entstammt Simula.
Beziehungsweise, wenn man jetzt hier nochmal die allwissende Müllhalde befragt, reden wir glaube ich im Besonderen von Simula 67 und das ist dann halt... 1967, es gab wohl so ein Simula 1 und ein Simula... 1967 kam dann halt mit den Objektenklassen, Unterklassen, virtuellen Methoden und so weiter.
Interessant vielleicht ist auch noch...
Die hatten echt schon ein Garbage Collection 1967.
Aber was man auch sehen muss, dass die meisten Programmiersprachen, also auch Algol beispielsweise oder eben auch Simula oder viele andere C++-Guides, teilweise hat man es versucht, ein bisschen zurückzudrängen. Aber es war so, die meisten Programmiersprachen wurden von Mathematikern am grünen Tisch entworfen. Und dann dauerte das 10 bis 20 Jahre bis die erste funktionierende Implementierung, also bis der erste Compiler, der wirklich diese Programmiersprache in der Lage war, auch so wie sie denn spezifiziert und definiert war, dann zu verarbeiten. Das heißt, von vielen Programmiersprachen...
So wie Telekommunikationsprotokolle, die von Telekom-Ingenieuren entwickelt werden.
Ja, so ungefähr. Oder ITU zumindest. Man setzte sich hin und hatte halt irgendwie eine Idealvorstellung, die hat man formuliert und dann geguckt, wie kriegt man sie umgesetzt. C++ hat ein bisschen den anderen Weg genommen, nämlich zu sagen, okay, wir brauchen, und das hat sich dann auch in der Philosophie umgesetzt, eine Lösung für Probleme von heute. Obwohl auch bei C++ es sehr, sehr lange gedauert hat, auch da ist der Standard den eigentlichen Compiler-Implementierungen doch deutlich vorausgeeilt. Aber man hat es zumindest versucht, doch recht nah, also die Lücke zwischen Theorie und Praxis nicht so groß werden zu lassen, wie das bei vielen anderen Programmiersprachen der Fall war.
Das heißt, der Bjarne Straustrup hat, nachdem er sich jetzt durch dieses Projekt von Simula hat da inspirieren lassen und festgestellt hat, schnelle Programmiersprache ist eine tolle Sache, man braucht auf jeden Fall Performance, man braucht auf jeden Fall den Kontakt zur Maschine, also zumindest sollte man nicht ihn von vornherein opfern, weil das eine negative Auswirkung haben kann. Auf der anderen Seite hat er aber auch gesehen, diese abstrakten Dinge in einer Programmiersprache zu haben, ist gut für den Programmierprozess und man braucht das schon. Sein Ansatz war, einen Weg zu finden, wie man das Performance integrieren kann, dass man sozusagen die Features hat, ohne die Performance an irgendeiner Stelle grundsätzlich zu beschränken, sondern wenn irgendjemand die Performance beschränkt, dass man das dann selber ist.
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt. Es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von niedergeschriebenen Design-Grundsätzen für die Programmiersprache. Eine davon ist, es darf unterhalb von C++ keinen Raum für eine weitere Programmiersprache außer Assembler geben. Das heißt...
Das hat er so gesagt?
Ja, das war ein ganz explizites Ziel des Assemblers. Die Kontrolle, die man mithilfe von C++ einfach ausüben kann, das ist keine Programmiersprache. Also, dass kein Raum dazwischen da sein soll.
Dass man keine benötigt.
Dass man keine benötigt, genau.
Maschinennah.
Ja, so maschinennah, wie man eben nur sein kann, so nah sollte C++ sein und auch immer bleiben. Und ich kann das auch nur aus der Praxis bestätigen, man kann auch in C++, obwohl der Compiler eine ganze Menge macht, kann man durchaus auch in C++ einfach Code schreiben, wo man sich überlegt, wie man denn so die Pipeline des Prozessors jetzt sättigt und mit unterschiedlichen Wortbreiten und Bitverschiebereien und Bitformulein ist es mir also durchaus gelungen, in C++ Code zu schreiben. Der brute force Code zum Beispiel habe ich mal in RGBA, wo man eben 3 bytes in 4 bytes umkopiert für Pixel-Operationen zu schreiben, der schneller lief, also in C++ geschrieben, der schneller funktionierte, als die in Assembler geschriebenen, in der libc befindlichen Routinen für denselben Zweck.
Also RGB Rot, Grün, Blau, RGBA mit Transparenzkanal.
Also im Prinzip einfach auf byte-Ebene, also einfache byte- und bit-Operationen.
Aber da braucht man dann schon irgendeinen Dahn. Da kann man jetzt nicht nur mit einem weißen Gürtel rumlaufen.
Ja, da muss man schon ein bisschen verstehen. Es hilft natürlich auch, Assembler zu verstehen. Man muss sich natürlich dann auch anschauen, was kommt denn dabei raus und ein Gefühl entwickeln für den Compiler, was tut der eigentlich. Aber dann funktioniert das. Dann kann man wirklich Code schreiben, also in C++, der so schnell läuft, dass es kaum möglich ist.
Das geht auch noch ohne, dass man zwei Nächte auf dem Berg stehen muss und VW Käfer auf seinen Händen balanciert, während man meditiert.
Das geht.
Also kann schnell sein und kann komplex sein.
Ja, und auf der anderen Seite, um das andere Ende der maximalen Abstraktion zu beleuchten, der Template-Mechanismus von C++. Also Templates kann man sich vorstellen, ist so eine Art Makro-Mechanismus, wo der Compiler bestimmte Ersetzungen durchführt beim Übersetzen. Dieser Mechanismus ist so mächtig, dass man festgestellt hat, angeblich nach der Standardisierung erst, dass dieser Mechanismus Turing-Complete ist. Und ein, der Kommentar dazu von einem Mitglied des Standardisierungskomitees als dieser Beweis geführt wurde, war, oh mein Gott, was haben wir getan?
Was ist da jetzt so besonders dran?
Der Punkt ist, dass man eine vollständige Programmiersprache hat, die vom Compiler ausgeführt wird. Also nicht das Ergebnis, sondern während des Übersetzungsvorgangs, durch diese Ersetzungen, die durchgeführt werden können. Die sind so mächtig, dass man damit ebenfalls alles tun kann. Also Touring Complete heißt...
Also man hat sozusagen prozedurale Makros, kann man sagen. Dass man sich seinen Source Code zusammenbauen kann und die Beschreibungssprache, in der man das tut, ist eigentlich so eine Programmiersprache wie C++ selbst. Natürlich mit einem anderen Zweck und einer anderen Gestaltung, aber so flexibel, dass man jetzt anfangen kann, ok, ich kann haben Schleifen und ich kann Datenstrukturen aufbauen, um zu definieren, wie ich jetzt meine Klasse habe.
Ich kann mein Programm, ich kann quasi so meinen Quellcode beliebig auffalten, vervielfältigen auf komplexeste Art und Weise. Ich kann mit einer Zeile komplexe, also komplette Klassenhierarchien erzeugen. Da gibt es auch ein Buch, also wo das zum ersten Mal wirklich gezeigt wurde. Die Mächtigkeit der Programmiersprache war von Alexandrescu, Modern C++ Design, was als es erschienen ist von manchen Leuten auch als Future C++ bezeichnet wurde, weil die Compiler, die zum Erscheinungsdatum auf dem Markt waren, und das war Ende der 90er eigentlich, sogar nach 2000 schauen, die hatten alle Argemühen, mit diesem C++ Code klarzukommen.
Er hat einfach mal definiert, was modern ist.
Er hat einfach mal gezeigt, was der Standard so hergibt, was man denn wirklich damit tun kann, wenn man es auf die Spitze treibt. Er hat da auch entsprechende Bibliotheken geschrieben. Da hat man eine wirklich unglaubliche Power, insbesondere deswegen. Lisp bietet auch ähnliche Möglichkeiten, aber wenn man bei C++ diesen Mechanismus nutzt, ist man in der Lage, Code zu produzieren, der dann wiederum so schnell ist, wie nur möglich. Man muss sich vorstellen, dass der Compiler teilweise gewaltige Mengen an Code erst mal produziert, anschließend wieder zusammenfaltet, sodass viel Code dann einfach auch verschwindet. Zur Compile-Zeit wird dann plötzlich wiederum eliminiert durch bestimmte Template-Mechanismen. Sodass man statt Fallunterscheidungen, die zur Laufzeit ausgeführt werden, macht man diese Fallunterscheidungen bereits im Compiler.
Genau, das ist ja auch einer der Kritikpunkte. Das ist auf jeden Fall immer eine Sache, die in der Diskussion ist. Die grundsätzliche Entscheidung, wie erreicht man Komplexität bei der Programmierung? Wie mache ich es mir möglichst einfach als Anwender einer Programmiersprache, um komplexe Systeme zu modellieren? Da gibt es viele Vertreter verschiedener Schulen. Vor allem fallen mir jetzt ein diejenigen, die grundsätzlich unterscheiden, zu denen zähle ich mich natürlich auch, in Programmiersprachen, die man als statisch bezeichnet und die man als dynamisch bezeichnet. Das ist natürlich alles wacky, wie auch alle anderen Begriffe von Objektorientiert und Klasse usw. Es gibt ja wirklich kaum irgendeinen wirklich keinen einzigen Begriff in der ganzen Programmiersprachenwelt, der nicht umstritten sei, wie er denn genau definiert ist. Aber hier denke ich, kann man grob unterscheiden zwischen den Sprachen, die halt die Entscheidung im Wesentlichen zur Übersetzungszeit machen, wie C++, und den Sprachen, die das eben dann zur Laufzeit tun.
Wobei man C++, muss man auch wieder sagen, bietet auch sämtliche Möglichkeiten oder eine Reihe von Möglichkeiten, um eben auch zur Laufzeit Unterscheidungen zu machen. Also auch dort gibt es eben sehr viel Runtime-Support, RTTI Runtime, Type Information, Dynamic Casts. Also auch dort gibt es halt sehr viel Unterstützung, um jetzt dynamische Programmierung tatsächlich vorzunehmen. Aber es gibt eben auch die statische. Also C++ ist weder rein dynamisch noch rein statisch, sondern C++ ist einfach, so schön heißt es, multiparadigmatisch. So kann man das bezeichnen. Also man kann in C++ jede Art von Programmierstil...
Aber das geht ja erst. Also als ich das erste Mal mir C++ angeschaut habe, das war irgendwann Anfang der 90er Jahre, da gab es das nicht. Also es gab überhaupt ganz viele Features nicht. Es gab keine Templates, es gab keine Runtime-Type-Information. Von Dynamic Cust habe ich bis heute noch nichts gehört. Und viele andere Sachen auch nicht. Also das UR C++, was eigentlich mal rauskam, war in meinen Augen zwar vielversprechend, aber irgendwie extrem unvollständig. Es war definitiv anders, als du jetzt sagst. Man konnte nicht alles machen in C++. Ganz im Gegenteil, sondern es war einfach statisch, es war beschränkt. Was man nicht zur Übersetzungszeit entscheiden konnte, muss man danach alles von Hand machen. Und das war natürlich extrem fehlanfällig. Und das ist ja genau das, was man nicht haben will. Was hat denn dann dazu geführt? Also ich meine, willst du mir jetzt sagen, dass das Bjarne Strohstroh von Anfang an dieses Endziel Templates und diese Vervollkommnung, die C++ jetzt hat, schon im Sinn hatte und er hatte bloß nicht genug Zeit, das rechtzeitig fertigzustellen? Oder kam das danach so als, oh Gott, wir müssen das fixen?
Also die waren tatsächlich im Standard. Also er hatte das sehr früh schon formuliert, alles. Also auch im Annotated Reference Manual taucht sehr viel davon auf. Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass zum einen die Compiler eben Jahre hinter dem hinterherhingten, was eigentlich sein sollte. Aber was dazu kam, war, dass auch nur in der Anfangszeit sehr wenig Leute verstanden haben, wie man den C++ jetzt eigentlich am besten benutzt. Das ist eben auch, wie gesagt, auch dieses Beispiel von Alexandrescu, dass es weit über zehn Jahre gedauert hat, bis man verstanden hat, wozu man den Template-Mechanismus überhaupt nutzen kann. Und so ist es mit vielen Sprachfeatures einfach gewesen. Und das ist das, was ich vorhin auch meinte, dass es einfach Zeit braucht. Und dadurch, dass man alle Freiheiten hat, dass man eine Weile braucht, um darauf zu kommen, wie man denn diese Freiheiten auch sinnvoll nutzt und was man halt tut und was man möglichst auch nicht tut. Weil sehr viele Sachen, die man tun kann, in C++ sollte man nicht tun.
Sollte man lieber lassen.
Also C++ hat unglaublich viele Features, von denen man von den meisten die Hände erlassen sollte. Also sozusagen so ein bisschen wie in der Schusswaffen-Analogie. Es ist komplett aufgerüstet, aber man darf nicht jede Taste drücken.
Also es gibt auch so wie gesagt auch wieder Anekdoten. Also C++ hat als meistgehasste Programmiersprache natürlich auch jede Menge Anekdoten und bösartige Witze von Hassan hervorgebracht. Zum Beispiel gibt es da auch die schönen Begriffe. Also wenn dein Hammer C++ ist, das fängt alles an wie ein Daumen auszusehen.
Das ist sicherlich...
Oder auch so ein... Ich mein bei C, also C gibt dir auch genug Seil, um dich darin aufzuhängen. Und C++ gibt dir zusätzlich das Baumobjekt, an dem du das Seil befestigen kannst.
Ja, aber warum sollte ich dann C++ nehmen? Ich meine, ich kenne die Diskussion auch immer mit der Geschwindigkeit, mit C++. Da sagt mir der C++-Programm ihrer, naja, ich nehme C++, weil das Programm schneller ist. Naja, aber ist es auch schneller fertig? Also für mich ist ein Programm, das ein halbes Jahr eher fertiggeschrieben ist, ist für mich schneller als eins, was in einem halben Jahr dann nur zehn Sekunden läuft.
Natürlich, ich meine, das sagt Strußtrupp auch immer bei Programmiersprachenvergleichen, man muss das natürlich immer im Kontext sehen. Und natürlich gibt es nicht die Programmiersprache wirklich für alles. Aber wenn es eben, wie gesagt, eine gäbe, die dem recht nahe kommt, dann wäre C++ das Ding. Der Punkt ist auch, in den meisten anderen Programmiersprachen gibt es einfach eine Grenze. Eine Grenze oder ein Abstand zur Maschine, den ich nicht unterschreiten kann. Nehmen wir mal, um jetzt auf das schöne Beispiel Java zu kommen, nehme ich mal an, ich schreibe jetzt einen Simulator, so wie Bjarne Stroostrup, für einen Rechner, oder ich simuliere ein Betriebssystem oder irgendwas. Damals war auch das Problem mit Simula, weswegen Simula so langsam war, war die Garbage Collection. Er brauchte die Garbage Collection gar nicht, weil sein Programm das Thema Ressourcen- und Speicherverwaltung selbst implementiert hat. Das heißt, es war Teil der Simulation. Warum soll ich, wenn ich ein System bauen will, zum Beispiel einen Garbage Collector, ich möchte gerne einen Garbage Collector programmieren. Zeig mir bitte, wie ich in Java einen vernünftigen Garbage Collector programmieren soll. Das heißt, wenn ich wirklich einen Garbage Collector programmieren möchte, dann brauche ich so etwas wie C++. Und da gibt es einen Haufen anderer Fälle, wo ich einfach bei anderen Programmiersprachen einfach Schicht, da ist einfach Ende. Und da bleibt mir dann nur entweder auf Assembler oder auf C oder auf irgendwelche anderen wenig Dinge zurückzugreifen, wo wiederum die Grenzen der Abstraktionsfähigkeit sehr schnell erreicht sind. Das ist so ein Punkt. Ein anderer Punkt, auch ganz wichtig, wenn wir jetzt mal, weil Java ist eine Programmiersprache, die so sehr stark auf dem Vormarsch ist. Ich kenne aktuell gar keine Nutzerzahlen, aber wie viele Programmierer Java tatsächlich einsetzen. Aber es könnten sogar mittlerweile mehr sein als C++-Programmierer.
Vorstellbar.
Wobei es solide Zahlen sind, da schwer tatsächlich ranzukommen. Aber C++ war noch so, auf jeden Fall Anfang 2000, doch die verbreitetste Programmiersprache, die von den meisten Programmierern genutzt wurde. Da ist halt einfach das Thema, was Java zum Beispiel nicht kann im Gegensatz zu C++, C++ ist, sich nahtlos mit anderen Programmiersprachen zu integrieren. Also versuch mal irgendwie Assembler-Code in Java unterzubringen oder irgendwie eine C-Library an Java ranzulinken. Klar, es geht irgendwie, aber nahtlose Integration, also es bricht.
Gut ist die Frage, ob das immer die Schuld von Java ist oder ob das nicht vielleicht die Schuld von C++ ist.
Es ist einfach eine Anforderung aus der Praxis. Ich habe halt einfach nun mal das Problem, dass ich bestimmten Assembler-Code habe oder bestimmten anderen Code. Die andere Sache ist, dass mich auch Java doch massiv auf obenden objektorientierten Programmierstil festlegt. C++ legt mich da gar nicht fest. Also nehmen wir zum Beispiel interessanterweise die Standard-Bibliothek oder die STL, was wahrscheinlich noch ein eigener Podcast wäre.
Also STL ist die Standard Templates Library. Das ist nicht nur das Feature Templates, sondern was wir auch noch mal ein bisschen genauer erklären müssen, sondern sozusagen dann eine Standard-Auslieferung von fertigen Templates, die man benutzen kann.
Von fertigen C++ Code, insbesondere wo ich Standard-Container wie Listen, Maps, Mengen und eine ganze Reihe von Algorithmen habe, die einfach ineinander passen und die den Vorteil haben, dass sie auch sehr schnell sind, also extrem performant. Und dass ich insbesondere diese Container sowohl mit eingebauten Typen, also so wie ganzen Zahlen, Floating Point Zahlen, also mit Build-in-Types, wie auch mit eigenen Objekten verwenden kann. Das ist halt auch in Java gibt es dort eigentlich eine 2-Klassen-Gesellschaft. Es gibt halt die eingebauten Typen, das sind so, und es gibt die Objekte. Also wenn ich eine Int habe, dann gibt es halt Int kleingeschrieben und Int großgeschrieben. Und das eine ist ein Objekt.
Aber das ist doch bei C++ genauso. Bei C++ gibt es die C-Welt. So, da gibt es auch das normale Int. Das ist dann auch kein Objekt.
Genau.
Und dann kann man da alles noch mal in Objekten zusammenbauen.
Aber die anderen Sprachmechanismen erlauben es mir im Gegensatz zu Java, diese Objekte gleich zu behandeln. Das heißt, ich kann eingebaute Objekte in Container stecken, wie auch eigene Objekte, also die anderen Sprachmechanismen, insbesondere Overloading, ermöglichen es mir, mich nicht darum kümmern zu müssen, ob es sich jetzt um ein Bild in Objekt oder um ein eigenes selbst gebautes Objekt handelt.
Gut, aber es ist ja dann doch immer noch was anderes. Es ist nicht komplett polymorphisch, das heißt, ich kann nicht wirklich alles genauso damit tun, wie ich es mit einem Objekt, das aus einer Klasse herausfällt, machen kann.
Doch, ich kann ihm natürlich keine Methoden verpassen. Das ist richtig, das brauche ich aber nicht, weil ich über Overloading als Mechanismus an der Stelle eine Funktion machen kann, die eine Int benutzt oder eine Implementierung für Int, die gewählt wird, genauso wie ich eine Implementierung für meine eigene Klasse machen kann. Also ich benutze das am laufenden Band und das ist ein wirklich ganz wichtiges Feature der Sprache, dass man tatsächlich diese Brücke oder diese Grenze, diese Zweiklassengesellschaft tatsächlich in der Lage ist, über die Overloading-Mechanismen einfach aufzuheben.
Okay, für meinen Geschmack sind wir noch ein bisschen zu breit und ein bisschen zu breit. Ich versuch das mal so ein bisschen zusammenzuziehen. Was würdest du sagen, sind die fünf wichtigsten Eigenschaften von C++, die diese Sprache im Wesentlichen definieren, die man entweder immer wieder benutzt oder auf jeden Fall benutzen sollte, weil sie eine sehr wertvolle Sache sind, die sozusagen dann auch in der Summe das eigentliche Wesen von C++ ausmachen. Also ich denke mal, Templates gehören auf jeden Fall dazu und die sollten wir auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen erläutern, weil ich noch nicht so den Eindruck habe, dass wir genug herausgearbeitet haben, was das eigentlich ist, außer dass es einen fancy Namen hat. Was wäre denn der Rest?
Ok, also das Thema Klassen hatten wir ja schon. Klassen mit Klassenhierarchie und eben diesen sogenannten Protection Model. Das heißt Public Private Protected Ableitung, wo halt man bestimmte Dinge verbergen kann. Also ich sag mal, ein Zugriffsschutz in der Programmiersprache noch mit drin hat. Das ist ja definitiv das Ding. Dann auch etwas, also in dem Zusammenhang virtuelle Funktionen, als Funktionen, die klassenzugehörig sind, sodass in einer Klassenhierarchie eben immer diejenige Funktion aufgerufen wird, die auch, ich sag mal, am meisten abgeleitet ist. Also sozusagen die richtige Funktion aufgerufen wird. Und das auf eine sehr, sehr effiziente Art und Weise. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Feature. Das sind jetzt die Dinge, die sich auch in Java oder C-Sharp in ähnlicher Form praktisch wiederfinden. Ganz wichtig, was wir auch nicht erwähnt hatten, bestimmte Laufzeitgarantien, die ich habe. Das Thema Konstruktoren, Destruktoren und Speicherallokation. Konstruktoren sind im Prinzip Code, den ich angeben kann, der beim Erzeugen eines Objekts ausgeführt wird. Destruktoren ist der Code, der ausgeführt wird, wenn die Lebenszeit eines Objekts abgelaufen ist, wenn das Objekt gelöscht werden soll, bevor der Speicher dealloziert wird. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Mechanismus. Und auch ein ganz elementares Mechanismus, um die Laufzeit zu managen, was aus meiner Sicht bei Java auch etwas missglückt ist. Ich kann dadurch in C++ einfach sagen, in einem Block Code bitte hier möchte ich gerne ein neues Objekt haben. Und wenn dieser Code Block auf irgendeine Art und Weise verlassen wird, egal wie, sei es weil man ans Ende kommt, sei es weil eine Return aufgerufen wird, oder sei es weil eine Exception geworfen wird, es gibt ja verschiedene Wege, wie man aus dem Code rauskommt, möchte ich, dass auf jeden Fall gesichert ist, dass in dem Moment, wo ich dieses Stück Code verlasse, halt eine bestimmte Funktion ausgeführt wird. Und das kann ich eben in C++ gut machen. Dann das ganze Thema Allokation, sowohl auf dem Heap, als auch auf dem Stack ist auf jeden Fall auch ein wichtiger Punkt, weil dadurch kann ich halt, also auf dem Stack, kann ich sehr effizient Speicher für kurze Zeit aluzieren und dealluzieren, das ist auch etwas, was ich in Java nicht so gut unter Kontrolle habe beispielsweise. Ok, Referenzen vielleicht noch. Du wolltest eigentlich nur fünf haben, aber so explizit, also der Einsatz von Referenzen gegenüber von Pointern ist auch etwas, was eine sehr hilfreiche Art und Weise ist. Man kann sagen, eine Referenz ist ein Pointer, der niemals null sein darf. So als Definition eine sehr nützliche, sehr effiziente Geschichte.
Das sind jetzt sechs oder so.
Das waren jetzt ja dann noch das ganze Thema Konstnis. Konstnis? Ja, dass man...
Dass Dinge konstant sein können.
Ja, dass Dinge konstant sein können. Aber das kann sich auch durch ganze Klassen quasi wie ein roter Faden hindurchziehen. Das heißt, ich kann eben bestimmte Funktionen sagen, diese Funktion verändert jetzt den Zustand meines Objekts nicht. Also sie greift nur lesend zu. Und so kann ich eben ein komplexes System bauen, wo mir der Compiler sicherstellt, dass ich in diesem System ausschließlich nur Lesezugriffe beispielsweise durchführe. Und wenn ich das verletze, sagt mir der Compiler hier, an der Stelle irgendwie willst du etwas tun, was kein Lesezugriff ist. Und das ist eben auch ein sehr mächtiger Mechanismus, der einem hilft, sehr viele Fehler zu vermeiden, wenn man ihn richtig einsetzt.
Ich muss sagen, die meisten dieser Sachen, die du jetzt aufgezählt hast, die klingen für mich wirklich nach Patchwork. Also sowas wie, hurra, ich habe jetzt auch einen Pointer, der nicht Null werden darf. Das ist so dieses, oh, wir haben jetzt endlich einen Fix gefunden für einen Bug, den wir so inherent von Anfang an in die Programmiersprache eingebaut haben. Jetzt schaffen wir es auch mal, dass unser Programm nicht abstürzt.
Nein, das ist ein ganz wichtiger, semantischer Unterschied tatsächlich. Weil der Vorteil, wenn ich eine Referenz habe, dann ist das wirklich an der Stelle eine Garantie, die ich bekomme. Das heißt, ich kann eine Referenz tatsächlich einsetzen, anstelle einer Variablen beispielsweise. Eine Variable kann dann eben eine Referenz auch sein. Ich kann sie so benutzen, als wäre das Ding dort an einer bestimmten Stelle, als hätte ich garantierten Speicher, im Gegensatz zu einem Pointer, der durchaus aus legitimen Gründen null sein kann.
Warum verzichtet man dann nicht gleich auf Pointer, wenn man die Referenz genauso verwenden kann wie ein Pointer?
Der Unterschied ist, dass ich das mit einem Pointer durchaus absichtlich signalisieren kann. Hier geht es zum Beispiel nicht mehr weiter. Also einen Pointer brauche ich, wenn ich etwa eine verkettete Liste mache und da ist irgendwann Ende, dann möchte ich gerne diesen speziellen Nullwert haben.
Dann könnte ich doch eine Referenz auf ein Objekt machen, was das Nullobjekt ist. Dann hätte ich doch genau den gleichen Effekt.
Nein, dann habe ich wiederum nicht diese Garantie. Und der Vorteil ist, dass diese Referenz immer gültig ist.
Na ist ja dann gültig. Die referenziert halt das Objekt, was Null ist. Null, das Void, ich bin das Nichts. Nichts wie Null, sondern halt das Nichts.
Ja, aber dann würde das wieder zu langsam sein. Zu anderen Problemen, zu Laufzeitproblemen führen. Also Referenzen ist auf jeden Fall...
Du weißt natürlich, worauf ich hinaus will. Du hörst den Unterton. Ich hatte ja auch mal den großartigen Podcast gemacht mit Andreas zu düllen. Eine Sprache, die ja sozusagen versucht, ein ähnliches Problem zu lösen, nämlich die Komplexität der Programmierung zu vereinfachen. Die, wie ich nach wie vor finde, für viele Sachen sehr einfache Antworten auch liefert. Wie zum Beispiel dieses Es gibt keine Pointer-Konfusion, weil es sind halt immer Referenzen. Und virtuelle Funktionen brauchen wir sowieso nicht, weil es ist sowieso alles dynamisch. Da braucht man nicht sich groß mit überladen beschäftigen, weil es wird sowieso alles zur Laufzeit entschieden. Und die Optimierung kommt dann halt später. Und ist natürlich das Rennen offen, was dann da jetzt das Schnellere ist am Ende. Ich kann verstehen, dass man häufig auch diese Optimierung auf Maschinenebene braucht, aber auf der anderen Seite 99 Prozent der Anwendungen, die ich jeden Tag verwende und über die ich am meisten schimpfe und die wirklich Performance gebrauchen können, sind wahrscheinlich in C++ programmiert. Ja, vielleicht nicht alle, aber so. Und brauchen aber diese Optimierung nicht. Und ich frage mich, leiden die da nicht eher noch drunter?
Ja, C++ ist sicherlich nicht für alles, aber an der Stelle müssen wir jetzt, glaube ich, doch mal in das Thema Philosophie auf jeden Fall abtauchen. Und insbesondere erstmal also Strohstrohps Philosophie. Und das liefert nämlich auch viele Antworten dann auf Fragen, warum C++ so ist, wie es ist, warum man sich vielleicht auch darüber ärgert. Und gerade wo du Dillen auch ins Gespräch bringst. Aber also Strohstrohp hat...
Ich wollte die Wunderwaffe ja nicht auspacken, aber du hast mich gezwungen.
Also Strohstrohp hat unter anderem eben auch Philosophie und Geschichte studiert. Und hat sich dort auch ein philosophisches Fundament besorgt, das ihn halt dann in seinen Überzeugungen, Entscheidungen geleitet hat. Und Strohstrohp sagt halt ihm stehen die Empiristen wesentlich näher, auf jeden Fall näher als die sogenannten Idealisten. Und Mystizisten kann er überhaupt nicht ausstehen. Und vielleicht gut, also Empiristen sind halt die Leute, die so Erkenntnisse aus Sinnes, also sie sagen, Erkenntnisse kommen ausschließlich aus Sinneserfahrung. Während, im Gegensatz die sogenannten Rationalisten sagen, Erkenntnisse kommen aus Vernunft. Nur durch Nachdenken kommt man zu Erkenntnissen. Dazwischen hängen wiederum die Idealisten, die sagen, das Wirkliche sind eben nur Ideen. Eigentlich gibt es nur Ideen. Alles, was wir wahrnehmen, sind nur Abbilder von Ideen. Das heißt, es gibt gar keine Wahrnehmung, sondern es gibt nur Ideen. Und die Rationalisten sagen wiederum, Sinneserfahrung hin oder her, universelle Grundsätze können wir nur mit Hilfe von Verstand erschließen. Das ist etwa das Koordinatensystem. Er ist aber ganz klar, sagt halt, er ist halt Empirist. Das heißt, Sinneserfahrung und Ideen und irgendwie Nachdenken und Verstand ist zwar ganz nett, aber am Ende zählt irgendwie die Sinneserfahrung. Die kleinen Probleme des täglichen Lebens sind wichtiger als die großen Pläne über das Schicksal der Menschheit. Er sagt auch, also so was weiß ich, über Plato und Kant beispielsweise, er sagte alles faszinierende Ideen, aber so auf fundamentaler Ebene unbefriedigend und einfach zu weit weg von der Alltagserfahrung. Dülln ist dann eher so ein System, ganz nett und so, aber eben die Alltagserfahrung ist dann doch noch eine andere.
Dülln ist Kommunismus, das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren.
Zumindest ist es nicht Empirismus, sondern es ist halt auch eher so ein Entwurf am grünen Tisch.
Also mit der Lisp-Vergangenheit würde ich das jetzt nicht als komplett aus der Luft gezogen beziehen.
Aber vielleicht gehen wir noch kurz den philosophischen Diskurs zu Ende.
Ich spüre nur gerade, dass ich dir mal ein bisschen wie ein Wind in die Klappe leiden muss.
Er ist ein großer Fan von Eben Kirkegaard, der seiner Meinung nach geradezu fanatische Sorge um das Individuum und an den Tag legt und eindringliche psychologische Einblicke in die einfache Existenz des Menschen liefert und keine grandiosen Schemata, im Gegensatz zu Hegel und Marx, die irgendwie alles so, wo die Massen im Vordergrund stehen, irgendwie der Arbeiter, die Arbeiter schafft und das Kapital und so. Das ist nicht sein Ding, sondern...
Aber immerhin, also Marx hatte natürlich das Klassensystem schon vor C++.
Und er wird dann sogar auch ganz böse. Er sagte mich irgendwie, also generell, wenn man Respekt für Gruppen, da wird es dann auch schon politisch, der den Respekt für das Individuum in der Gruppe nicht mit einschließt, ist überhaupt kein Respekt. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie, so ich sag mal, den Programmierer oder den Entwickler oder die Gruppe der Programmierer irgendwo betrachte, oder respektieren will und denen was Gutes tun will, dann muss ich vor allem irgendwie mir die Nöte des einzelnen Programmierers in seiner Verschiedenheit, in seiner Unvollkommenheit, in seiner Verzweiflung, man muss auch mal Ausnahmen machen. Und man kann insbesondere die Leute nicht über einen Kamm scheren. Und wenn irgendjemand halt, ja, das hat er auch erkannt, also er meinte auch viele Dinge an C++ gehen ihm selber gegen den Strich. Aber er hat gesagt, hey, aber es gibt Leute, die lieben diese Dinge. Und nur weil ich sie scheiße finde, so habe ich nicht das Recht, den Leuten, die halt vielleicht anders denken und anders arbeiten als ich, diese Dinge wegzunehmen.
So kriegt man seine Clubräume nie aufgeworben.
Es gibt, genau, und da ist die Frage, okay, wo hat das natürlich seine Grenzen? Weil natürlich darf man nun, also darf das auch nicht in Beliebigkeit enden. Und die Grenze für ihn ist halt dort die Alltagserfahrung. Man sagt, okay, aber im Alltag, also im täglichen Einsatz hat sich das bewährt und das hat sich nicht bewährt. So, und das ist einfach die Grenze, oder? Irgendwie 50.000 Leute nutzen dieses Feature oder 100.000 oder eine Million und kommen damit klar. Das heißt, das ist Fakt und das andere Feature, irgendwie kein Mensch benutzt es seit fünf Jahren und deswegen kann das irgendwie theoretisch noch so toll sein, aber es hat halt einfach den Test vor der Realität nicht bestanden, egal wie großartig der Gedanke dahinter sein mag. Und das ist, um jetzt wieder zu dem Düllen, was es ja anders gegeben hat, ich muss sagen, Düllen hat halt einfach diesen Test vor der Realität nicht bestanden. Also es sieht nicht so aus, als würde es abheben. Es ist nichts gegen Kommunismus oder Marxismus oder irgendeine nette, schicke Philosophie, die halt die Welt erklärt oder die Welt besser macht. Also kann man viel Spaß und Befriedigung rausziehen. Aber wenn Arbeit getan werden muss, dann greift man doch lieber gerne auf was Bewertes zurück.
C++ ist natürlich jetzt schon relativ lange am Markt. Es ist ja eigentlich in breiter Verwendung. Allerdings, wenn ich jetzt gerade mal so überlege, gibt es eigentlich ein Betriebssystem, das in C++ programmiert ist?
Na ja, also große Teile von OS X sind interessanterweise die ganzen OS X Treiber.
Das IO-Kit ist Embedded C++.
Das IO-Kit ist Embedded C++, ein bisschen reduziert, ja, aber letztendlich ist das C++. Ansonsten, na, wie hieß es noch? Die B-Box, BOS.
War das wirklich komplett in C++ bis nach unten?
Also soweit ich weiß, ich hab's mir nie angeguckt, aber ich hab nur C++.
Die Erinnerung, dass sie dir das behauptet haben, das hab ich auch noch, so richtig wissen, ob sie es wirklich getan haben, das weiß ich nicht.
Also klar, ganz unten hast du irgendwo ein bisschen Assembler.
Ja, das mein ich ja nicht. Aber ich freu mich jetzt gerade, weil sie diese Aussage im Raum stellt, na ja, man muss ja auch ran irgendwie ans Bit. Klar, kann ich verstehen, braucht man definitiv, gerade wenn man ein OS macht und wenn es mit Prozessorialitäten zu tun hat, dann ist sowas wie Bit-Alignment und tra-la-la und garantiertes Timing und so weiter. Vollstes Verständnis dafür. Nur sehe ich halt, dass eigentlich C++ dafür, wofür es so sehr geeignet ist, eigentlich selten verwendet wird. Sondern heute sehe ich vor allem große Applikationen, Middlewares und End-User-Anwendungen, GUI-Applikationen, die dann mitgemacht werden, Photoshop, tra-la-la, dieser ganze Mumpitz. Und vermisse einfach eine bestimmte Eleganz und kann auch diese Performance, die immer so beschworen wird bei C++ real nicht so sehen, dass ich jetzt anderen Programmiersprachen da vorteile.
Ich glaube sämtliche größeren Echtzeitsysteme, die irgendwas Komplexeres tun, also gerade im Bereich der Grafik. Da ist einfach C++ so das Mittel der Wahl. Ich vermute mal auch, ich weiß nicht, wie es aussieht bei komplexen Steuerungen im Bereich der Luft- und Raumfahrt. Aber soweit ich das sehen kann, ist dort auch C++ einfach stark. Und bei den Betriebssystemen, also es ist vielleicht schade oder es ist ein Problem, dass viele Betriebssysteme nicht in C++ geschrieben sind, weil, da fand ich das Beispiel hier auch auf dem Kongress, das Thema I. Wie es auf dem Mac funktioniert versus so die Art und Weise, wie unter Linux Treiber geschrieben werden, wo man den Code von einem Treiber kopiert und dann Änderungen macht und einfach leider keine Möglichkeit hat. Ja, diese seit, ich sag mal 20 Jahren Bekannten und so seit 10 Jahren Verstandenen oder breitverstandenen Möglichkeiten zur Abstraktion einzusetzen. Und eines der wichtigsten Prinzipien, auch im Zusammenhang mit Extreme Programming, aber wenn nicht gar das wichtigste Prinzip, ist das Dry-Prinzip Don't Repeat Yourself. Sprich, in dem Moment, wo ich anfange hinzugehen und irgendwie mir ein Stück Code dupliziere und dort Änderungen vornehme, ist das zwar meistens der schnellste Weg oder oft der schnellste Weg zum Ziel, aber auch dann der Weg in die Hölle. Weil in dem Moment, wo ich nämlich plötzlich einen Fehler finde, der im ursprünglichen Code drin war, habe ich keine Ahnung, an wieviel Stellen dieser Fehler, an wieviel Stellen dieser Fehler kopiert wurde.
Ja, aber macht C++ an der Stelle da wirklich so einfach? Ja. Also da sehe ich ja, gut, ich mache erst mal die Kritik und du kannst sie dann wieder legen. Also ich sehe jetzt zunächst einmal natürlich die Eigenschaft von C++, da statisch zu sein. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo das Programm übersetzt ist und wo ich irgendwie laufenden Code habe, dann ist das Programm weitgehend auf seine Datentypen festgelegt. Er kann nicht zur Laufzeit mal mit anderen und neuen Daten umgehen. Er ist nicht so in dem Sinne Polymorph. Ich muss dann halt, wenn Ähnliches getan werden soll mit anderen Datentypen, muss ich dann eben auch wieder einen neuen Code erzeugen. An der Stelle mögen jetzt vielleicht die Templates mit reinspielen, das kannst du ja mal kurz erklären. Also das ist auf jeden Fall so ein Problem, was ich an der Stelle sehe. Ich finde das jetzt nicht unbedingt einfach auf den ersten Blick. Was ist denn das mit diesem Template? Vielleicht kannst du das nochmal ein bisschen genauer erläutern, weil ich glaube, dass es eine der wesentlichen Argumente, warum C++ doch nicht so scheiße ist.
Also das eine hat mit dem anderen erst mal nicht unbedingt was zu tun, aber zunächst mal mit den Templates. Im einfachsten Fall unter Java kennt man sie nun mittlerweile auch als sogenannte Generics. Generics ist zunächst mal, dass ich meinen Typen, den ich in einem bestimmten Objekt oder in einem bestimmten Funktionsblock habe, dass ich zur Compile Zeit diesen Typen nicht vorher festlege, sondern in der Lage bin, dieses Objekt mit unterschiedlichen Typen zu instanzieren. Also im einfachsten Fall, sagen wir mal, ich habe jetzt eine Matrizenmultiplikation und möchte einmal Fließkommazahlen, also mit einfacher Genauigkeit, mit Floats, oder mit Fließkommazahlen mit doppelter Genauigkeit den Code implementieren in C. Beispielsweise müsste ich das Ganze zweimal hinschreiben. Einmal mit Floats und einmal mit Doubles. In C++ setze ich eben ein Template-Argument davor und sage dann, jetzt hätte ich bitte gerne einmal das Objekt oder die gesamte Funktionalität mit Floats und einmal mit Doubles. Und der Compiler generiert dann einmal den Code, wo Floats verwendet werden, und einmal den Code, wo Doubles verwendet werden.
Aber der Algorithmus als solcher bleibt der gleiche?
Der Algorithmus bleibt der gleiche. Ich muss ihn nur einmal hinschreiben, und er wird aber vom Compiler eben zweimal, einmal für Floats, einmal für Doubles, meinetwegen auch noch für Ins und Shorts. Und wenn ich will, gut, bei Matrizen macht das keinen Sinn, aber ich kann es dann auch für Strings oder für, dass ich kleine grüne Männchen halt dort hineinreichen. So, das ist jetzt erstmal sozusagen die Basis. Jetzt kommt aber noch ein zweiter Mechanismus hinzu, das sogenannte Overloading. Overloading in C++ bedeutet, dass wenn ich eine Funktion habe, dann hat die eine Argumentliste mit einer bestimmten Signatur. Also ich habe als erstes möchte die Funktion gerne eine Integer haben, als zweites meinetwegen ein String und als drittes Argument eine Fließkommazahl. Eine sogenannte Signatur. Ich kann jetzt eine Funktion mit demselben Namen, aber unterschiedlichen Signaturen haben. Also ich kann eine haben, die... Oder machen wir es mal etwas einfacher. Das Beispiel angenommen, ich habe eine Funktion, die heißt jetzt Maximum. Dann kann ich jetzt eine Funktion haben, die mir das Maximum, die halt als Argument eine Fließkommazahl, eine Float, oder eine Double, oder eine Int, oder ein Character nimmt. Die heißen alle identisch, Maximum, und es gibt aber eben vier verschiedene Implementierungen davon, die jeweils anderen Code ausführen, die ich einfach direkt hinschreiben kann. Und der Compiler, ich muss aber, wenn ich es benutze, sage ich nur Maximum, stecke irgendein Argument rein, und der Compiler wählt den dazu passenden Typen aus meiner Liste von Funktionen, die ich hingeschrieben habe, aus. So richtig mächtig wird das jetzt in Verbindung mit dem Template-Mechanismus. Ich könnte natürlich auch Maximum kann ich jetzt auch als Template-Funktion hinschreiben und kann halt eine allgemeine Maximum-Funktion, die als Implementierung, wo drin steht, also Maximum, wenn a größer b, dann gibt a zurück, sonst b. Die kann ich als allgemeine Funktion hinschreiben. Jetzt kann ich aber eben mit diesem Overloading eben bestimmte Spezialisierungen für ganz bestimmte Typen machen. Also ich kann halt für eine Float- oder für eine Double-Funktion jetzt nochmal extra eine Funktion hinschreiben. Und die wird dann ausgewählt statt der allgemeinen Template-Variante. Das heißt, ich kann quasi in meinem Typen-System, was ich habe, kann ich sagen, okay, hier ist die allgemeine Lösung. Und für bestimmte Typen habe ich hier jetzt noch eine spezielle Sonderlösung. Und als Benutzer, der jetzt die Funktion aufruft, brauche ich mich nicht darum zu kümmern, welche Lösung jetzt genommen wird. Er nimmt halt eben genau entsprechend die passende. Und dieses Ganze wiederum kann ich über mehrere Stufen hinweg machen.
Was für Stufen?
Naja, ich kann Objekte haben, die mit Klassen, die über Template-Argumente instanziert werden. So, kann jetzt Spezialisierungen haben. Und kann jetzt wiederum sagen, ok, wenn diese Spezialisierung, wenn dieser Spezialisierungsfall eintritt, also wenn es eine Double ist, dann bitte instanziere dieses Objekt mit wiederum dem und dem Code. Und das kann ich eben, wie gesagt, über mehrere Stufen hinweg machen. Das heißt, ich habe einen bestimmten Typ. Aufgrund dieses Typen entscheide ich, welcher Code genommen wird. Dieser Code wiederum nimmt, verwendet wiederum ein weiteres Objekt zur Implementierung, was wiederum Template-Argumente hat, die aber eventuell ganz andere sein können. Das heißt, ich kann mir sozusagen so ein Geflecht, ein Typensystem aufbauen.
Aber warum sollte ich das tun? Das klingt jetzt kaum komplizierter. Mir ist jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig klar geworden, warum sollte ich diese Qual auf mich nehmen, so viele einzelne Entscheidungen zu fällen, nur damit es dann irgendwie etwas schneller läuft? Ich meine, in der dynamischen Sprache habe ich all das, was du jetzt erzählt hast, soweit ich dir habe folgen können. Sozusagen beschreibst du einfach das Default-Verhalten an der dynamischen Programmiersprache. Es wird einfach zur Laufzeit das Richtige genommen, fertig.
Erstens passiert das halt nicht zur Laufzeit, sondern zur Kompilzeit.
Aber ist das wirklich ein Vorteil?
Ein Anwendungsfall beispielsweise, der halt sehr nett ist, angenommen. Ich habe eine Funktion, sogenannten Remote Procedure Call meinetwegen. Das heißt, ich habe eine Funktion, die möchte ich lokal aufrufen, möchte aber, dass die Argumente dieser Funktion eingepackt werden.
Also willst du ein Marshaling haben, damit man das über das Netz transparent machen kann?
Genau, ich will ein Marshaling haben. Ich möchte gerne, dass die Sachen eingepackt werden, dass sie irgendwie übers Netz verschickt werden. Am anderen Ende bitte wieder ausgepackt und dort wieder aufgerufen werden.
Das heißt, du brauchst so eine Proxy-Funktion, die du aufrufst, die für den Aufrufen so aussieht, als wäre es die richtige, die aber eigentlich nichts anderes macht, als das über das Netz zu schicken.
Genau, entweder übers Netz schicken oder meinetwegen, ich möchte auch gerne Sprachgrenzen überwinden, das heißt, ich möchte gerne eine C++-Funktion von einer anderen Sprache aus aufrufen oder umgekehrt, oder Typenkonversion in eine andere Sprache haben. Entweder gibt es dort den Mechanismus, was man lange auch benutzt hat oder auch noch teilweise benutzt, sind sogenannte IDL-Compiler, wo ich einen Code-Generator anwerfe. Der generiert mir dann so einen Glue-Code, der irgendwie Dinge tut. Also ich habe dann halt Code-Generatoren. In C++ brauche ich diesen Code-Generator einfach nicht, sondern ich kann den Compiler als Code-Generator einsetzen. Und kann jetzt beispielsweise über so eine Hierarchie von Spezialisierungen und Klassen aus einem einfachen Typen alle Informationen rausziehen. Als Typen in dem Fall wäre das der Funktions-Zeiger-Typ, da ist sämtliche Typ-Information über die Argumente mit drin enthalten. Denen kann ich einfach auseinander falten mit entsprechendem Overloading und dafür sorgen, dass der Compiler automatisch meinen Code für das Marshalling generiert und umgekehrt auf der anderen Seite wieder den Code fürs Unmarshalling. Und brauche halt meine Sprache nicht zu verlassen, brauche keine hässlichen Code-Generatoren, die irgendwie Code erzeugen, indem ich dann rumeditiere und dann ändert sich das Interface und dann muss ich halt irgendwie den Code anpassen.
Aber was wird da jetzt benutzt? Wird die Runtime Type-Information benutzt?
Nee, da werden Templates und Overloading benutzt und das macht der Compiler komplett zur Compile-Zeit. Da ist nichts mit Runtime Type-Information, sondern das ist...
Ich muss schon irgendwie was speziell hinschreiben, dass ich das möchte. Ich muss jetzt irgendwie sagen, ich baue hier die Proxy-Funktion für eine Funktion, die so und so ist.
Ja, so ungefähr. Wenn man sich das anschauen will, ist halt dort Alexandrescu Modern C++ das Ding. Oder vielleicht eine einfache Sache, wenn ich angenommen habe, ich habe zwei Protokolle, die ich übereinander stapeln möchte. Ich habe meinetwegen ein Netzwerkprotokoll auf der Transportschicht, wo Pakete hin und her geschickt werden. Und ich habe einfach Protokolle, die ich übereinander stapeln möchte. In C wäre der Weg, ich gehe hin und verpointere dann die Sachen miteinander. Ich habe oben einen HTTP-Protokoll und möchte dann das HTTP entweder über einen TCP fahren oder ich möchte das Ganze über eine Shared-Memory-Verbindung fahren als Transportprotokolle. In C hätte ich dann irgendwelche Funktionspointer und würde dann einmal Funktionspointer auf meine TCP-Transportebene und zum anderen Funktionspointer auf meine Shared-Memory-Transportgeschichte da reinreichen. In C++ mit dem Template-Mechanismus habe ich jetzt noch eine dritte Möglichkeit. Dort kann ich halt das ganze Policy-Based machen. Das heißt, ich habe eine Klasse, die macht meine TCP, eine andere Klasse, die macht meine Shared-Memory-Kommunikation. Ich habe eine dritte Klasse, die macht irgendwie HTTP. Und ich kann jetzt dort einfach diese Klasse mit meinem unteren Protokoll instanzieren und bekomme dadurch zur Kompilzeit eine. Neue Klasse, die einen neuen statischen Protokoll stackt, der zur Kompilzeit zusammengebaut wird und dadurch einfach entsprechend effizient ist. Oder vielleicht, gut, das Beispiel ist vielleicht nicht ganz ideal, aber für das man häufig, also für WS einsetzen, angenommen, ich habe eine Implementierung von irgendwas, die ist multithreaded und eine nicht multithreaded Implementierung. So einmal mit, einmal ohne Synchronisation. Dann kann ich dort, indem ich mir so ein Policy-Objekt baue, kann ich halt einmal die multithreaded und einmal die single-threaded Variante bauen, indem ich einfach nur ein Template-Argument austausche. Und schon führt das dazu, dass ich eben eine single-threaded, eine multithreaded Variante habe und das zieht sich dann meinetwegen durch das gesamte Programm. Ein modernes If-Dev sozusagen.
Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen aus deinen Beispielen die knallige Idee rauszuziehen. Ich muss sagen, noch versage ich da ein bisschen, da wirklich jetzt die Revolution drin zu sehen.
Es ist keine Revolution.
Zumindest die Revolution meiner Programmieransätze. Also wo ich sage, ja, okay, alles klar, das löst jetzt irgendwie eine ganze Menge Probleme, weil das sind ja nun alles spezielle Sachen, wo ich mir auch tausend andere Ansätze vorstellen könnte, die nicht weniger kompliziert klingen.
Es löst einmal das Problem. Natürlich kann man jedes Problem auf sehr viele verschiedene Arten lösen. In dem Fall ist noch der Vorteil, dass der Compiler durch sein Typensystem, also in Verbindung mit dem Typensystem, mit dem Konstnis, dass der Compiler dir sehr viele Fehler einfach erkennt und dir sagt, hey, hier ist ein Problem. Das heißt, du hast unter C++ sehr häufig den Effekt, wenn du richtig C++ programmierst, dann brauchst du ziemlich lange, um das Ganze durch den Compiler zu bekommen. Aber nachdem du es einmal durch den Compiler durchhast, funktioniert das sehr häufig bereits. Wenn du eben beim Design die richtigen Paradigmen benutzt hast, das ist tatsächlich sehr oft der Effekt, wenn du C++ benutzt oder wenn du es richtig benutzt, wenn du die Mechanismen richtig benutzt, dass sehr komplexe Dinge plötzlich auf Anhieb funktionieren.
Was würdest du denn jetzt empfehlen für jemanden, der so in Grundzügen vielleicht auch schon in Grundzügen C++ kann, vielleicht auch schon seit ein paar Jahren aktiv betreibt? Du hast ja die These aufgestellt, man müsse C++ noch wirklich lange vor sich her treiben, bis man das Beast wirklich gezähmt hat. Was würdest du denn so raten, an welche Ressourcen man sich ranmacht, um der Sache wirklich herzuwerden?
Ja, bei den Ressourcen kann man sagen, also ein Muss natürlich für jeden C++-Programmierer ist das Buch von Strowstrup, das C++ Programming Language. Ich glaube aktuell ist immer noch die dritte Ausgabe. Das ist so das Standardwerk. Für Einsteiger ist es manchmal, das ist auch sehr beliebt von Lippmann, der C++ Primer, der etwas angenehmer die Dinge darstellt, aber irgendwann liest man dann eher den Strowstrup. Da steht auch fast alles drin, was man wissen muss. Da kann man alles nachlesen. Wenn man jetzt den, die schneller zu den Dahn kommen will, gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Protagonisten, die sehr gute Bücher geschrieben haben. Allen voran Scott Mayers, der mit seiner Effective C++ und More Effective C++ Reihe sehr viele nützliche Idiome beschrieben hat. Alexander Rescu habe ich genannt. Modern C++ Design ist einfach ein Ding. Dann gibt es noch andere Dinge, die man sich auch hinstellen sollte bei den Büchern. Für die Standard-Library ist C++ Standard-Library das Werk. Irgendwann kann man sich dann auch noch Larkos mit Large-Scale-C++ designen. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch noch ein Thema. Dann gibt es noch ein Buch zum Tunen. Wenn man C++ gut schnell machen will, gibt es noch einen Efficient C++ von Bolkar und Mayhew, wo wirklich Hands-on-Tipps um C++-Programme schneller zu machen, die auch sehr gut funktionieren. Das ist so das Thema Bücher. Da reicht aber auch das, was ich jetzt genannt habe. Da kann man ganz gut Zeit mit verbrauchen.
Ich finde es bedenklich, dass man Bücher braucht, um die Programmiersprache effektiv und effizient oder large scale.
Anzuwenden. Es gibt eine sehr berühmte Newsgroup, C++ Moderated oder CLCM genannt. Da sollte man zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt mal ein halbes Jahr oder Jahr rumhängen.
Ist das noch eine von diesen Newsgroups, wo es um das Thema geht?
Die ist halt moderated. Da sind halt die ganzen Gurus. Man sollte also mindestens drei bis sechs Monate mitlesen, bevor man dort auch nur daran denkt, auch nur zu posten. Weil erstens macht man sich leicht lächerlich. Beziehungsweise kommt gar nicht an der Moderation vorbei. Ich hab mir das tatsächlich auch mal angetan. Ich hab mal so ein Jahr lang jeden Tag ein bis zwei Stunden.
Wie viel wird da gepostet?
Zwischen 20 und 40 pro Tag an Messages.
Und die alle auf einem zweiten, dritten Dagen sind?
Ja, es sind durchaus praktische Probleme. Viel wiederholt sich auch. Es gibt natürlich auch eine lange FAQ. Da kriegt man sehr viel vom Wesen der Dinge mit. Dann boost.org als Website. Auf jeden Fall ist es ein Thema, wo qualitativ sehr hochwertige C++ Bibliotheken zu finden sind, die zwar noch nicht in den Standard eingeflossen sind, die aber durchaus die Qualität haben mit der Standardbibliothek vergleichbar. Das sind so die wichtigsten.
boost.org. Achso, das ist sozusagen ein Library-Verzeichnis. Ist das so ein bisschen das C-Pan des C++?
Das C++ lebt man sich nicht so mal eben. Das Standard-Komitee ist halt sehr zurückhaltend mit dem Standardisieren von Bibliotheken. Bei Java, da sind ja im Wochen- und Monatsrhythmus irgendwelche neuen Dinge rausgehauen worden. Ein Jahr später haben wir festgestellt, es ist wohl doch nichts. Dann machen wir jetzt mal wieder was Neues. So etwas gibt es bei C++ nicht.
Entweder ist es das letzte Wort oder es gibt kein Ding.
Da wird um die meisten Dinge auf sehr hohem Niveau sehr lange gerungen. Die Dinge müssen auch schon proven sein. Da wird nichts, keine Quick Hacks oder so rausgetan. Es ist eine Auseinandersetzung auf sehr hohem intellektuellen Niveau, die da stattfindet, aber wiederum mit sehr viel Praxisbezug. Einerseits sehr theoretisch, auf der anderen Seite sehr pragmatisch, was dort passiert.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns ein bisschen verzettelt, was die Diskussion der Details betrifft. Es gibt immer mehrere Ansätze, wie man das machen kann. Manches erscheint aus einem bestimmten Blickwinkel heraus kompliziert, was für den anderen noch eine sehr einfache Sache zu sein scheint. Da ist natürlich bei C++ mit diesem Ansatz, wir wollen möglichst viel zum Zeitpunkt der Übersetzung des Programmes entscheiden können, damit wir danach mit so wenig Variants zu leben haben, wie irgendwie möglich. Interpretiere ich das richtig?
Das ist eine Variante. C++ unterstützt die freie Wahl.
Das klingt für mich schon ein bisschen nach Pearl.
Ich mag das nicht, warum mag ich das nicht? Du bist dann wahrscheinlich eher so ein Maxist oder vielleicht ein Mystizist. Das kann schon sein. Also erstmal wie gesagt, C++ versucht halt nicht allen das eine Ding über zu helfen, sondern eben akzeptiert, dass so verschiedene Menschen auf verschiedene Arten denken und zu verschiedenen Zeiten.
Das ist auch eine Competition sozusagen um den besten Weg. Also man schreibt einen nicht vor, sondern man macht eine Plattform, auf der jeder sozusagen seinen eigenen Weg finden kann und mehrere Systeme können coexistieren. Okay, dafür habe ich verstanden.
Also mehrere Paradigmen eben auch. Und der Punkt ist, also auch eben bei C++, ja, also Strohstrup hatte halt eine Ablehnung dagegen, Leute dazu zu zwingen, Dinge auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise zu tun. Weil er der Meinung ist, sagen wir mal, jetzt bei der Philosophie das so. Und da bin ich absolut bei ihm, dass geschichtlich auch die größten Katastrophen durch Idealisten verursacht worden sind, die andere nur zu ihrem Besten zu irgendetwas zwingen wollten. Ja, aber so was, so ein Idealismus ist zwar nett so, man meint irgendwie im Besitz des Heiligen Grails zu sein, und alle müssen es jetzt irgendwie so tun, aber irgendwie das führt halt aus seiner Sicht nicht zum Leiden Unschuldiger, aber das Schlimmste ist, es bringt sogar auch noch Wahn und Verderben über diese Idealisten.
Ich habe eine These, vielleicht trifft es das ja. Ich habe so langsam den Eindruck, es ist eigentlich nicht angemessen C++ als Programmiersprache zu sehen, sondern es ist eigentlich mehr ein Programmier-OS. Es ist mehr so eine Umgebung, in der man seinen Programmieransatz implementieren kann, ohne dass man zu sehr darauf festgelegt wird, wie man das tut.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
So etwas Offenes wie diese Templates, dass ich eine Programmiersprache schreibe, die mir meine Klassen, meine Datenmodelle, innerhalb des Übersetzungsprozesses des Programms, zu Compile-Time, wenn man so schön sagt, schafft. Das ist ja dann eigentlich ein OS. Ich bin ja in meinem Compiler, ich programmiere in meinem Compiler und baue mir dort meine Welt zusammen.
Aber das ist nur eben nur eine Art, wie ich es machen kann. Das ist eine Art, ich kann es so machen.
Aber ist das nicht so the way to go?
Das ist eine Art es zu machen. Ich kann es aber auch völlig ignorieren. Ich kann brutal, ich kann ganz brutal, also mit oder ohne Templates, aber ich kann das gesamte Typensystem komplett aushebeln, wenn ich will. Ich kann beliebig rumcasten, ich kann irgendwie sagen, was interessieren mich jetzt die Typen? Ich kann eine Union machen, ich kann sagen irgendwie, ok, Compiler, das ist zwar jetzt eine Fließkommazahl, aber ich will das jetzt irgendwie als ganze Zahl behandeln. Ich kann in sehr weiten Grenzen, ich kann jederzeit irgendwie dem Compiler sagen, leck mich am Arsch, ich weiß es besser, so, tu was ich tue.
Genau, das ist ja das, was ich meine. Es ist mir eine Umgebung, in der man sich sozusagen sein Featureset, der Programmiersprache, die man benutzen möchte, selber definieren.
Aber es ist nach oben beschränkt. Es ist tatsächlich eher eine Sprache, also eher eine offene Sprache, wo ich einfach jeden Art von Sprachstil pflegen kann. Ich kann irgendwie Lyrik, ich kann Gesetze damit schreiben. Ich kann totalen Schwachsinn formulieren. Ich kann rumstammeln damit. Ich kann halt tausend Dinge machen. Und eins ist es eben nicht, es ist keine Umgebung. Im Gegensatz zu Java, das ist auch ganz wichtig.
Okay, ich habe auch schon gerade ein besseres Wort gefunden. Ich sage Programmiersystem.
Es ist eine Sprache. Es ist einfach nur eine Sprache. Und die bietet ein paar Garantien. Und bietet Unterstützung für eine Reihe von Paradigmen. Also um sie nochmal aufzuzählen. Also einmal dieses statische Typensystem ist auf jeden Fall eins. Dann dynamische Programmierung. Also das Laufzeit, das ganze Runtime-System auf jeden Fall. Dann habe ich natürlich alles komplett, was C mir auch bietet. Das heißt die reine prozedurale Programmierung. Ich kann durchaus mich auch im rein im funktionalen Bereich bewegen. Ich kann zum Beispiel in der Standardbibliothek Dinge machen, dass ich mir funktionale Objekte baue, die ich irgendwo reinwerfe und mir darüber meine Algorithmen zusammenbaue.
Also ich kann Funktionen als Parameter übergeben?
Das geht sogar auf drei verschiedene Arten. Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, es gibt eine CountIf-Funktion und da kann ich dann halt einen Prädikat reinwerfen, was entweder ein Function-Pointer ist oder was sogar über den Template-Mechanismus als statische Funktion vom Compiler bereits ausgewertet wird.
Jetzt, es gibt eine Funktion. Also in meiner Funktion, in der Programmiersprache reden wir davon, dass dann Funktionen so fast class objects sind, dass ich mit denen genauso umgehen kann wie mit dem Int. Dass ich so eine Funktion irgendwie mir in meinen Array reinsortieren kann und rausholen kann mit einer Zufallszahl.
Auch solche Dinge. Ich kann zum Beispiel durch Überladen des Klammer-Operators, also kann ich halt mir, das ist eine Art, wie man gerne Funktionsobjekte macht. Ich kann Konstruktoren verwenden für dieselbe Geschichte. Oder Funktions-Pointer-Objekte. Das geht in die Tiefe.
Okay, ich wollte da nur mal kurz einhaken, weil jetzt fällt mir gerade wieder eine Sache auf. Und das ist auch das, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe. So dieses Perl, dieses, there's always one more way to do it. Ich hab da ein gewisses Verständnis für, dass man das so sieht. Und dass man so breite Stile, man will sie alle irgendwie im Haus haben und jeder soll hier glücklich sein. Und für jeden gibt es irgendwie den passenden Waffenschrank. Und dann kann jeder so ballern nach seiner Fasson, wie er möchte. Ist ja auch super. Und wenn es darum geht, das Ziel zu erreichen, ist das alles super. Allerdings bei Perl zum Beispiel, in gewisser Hinsicht sehe ich das halt auch bei C++, tendiert man dann eben auch zu so Write-Only-Programmen, die dann einfach wirklich nur ein Programmierer schreibt das. Und außer ihm ist niemand in der Lage, diesen Programmierstil, den er dort an den Tag gelegt hat, so in irgendetwas anderes zu inkorporieren, weil einfach der Programmierstil so unterschiedlich ist. Während ich bei homogeneren Systemen, wie Lisp-basierte Systeme, ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit Dillen anfangen, mit der Sprache auch ein gewisser Duktus einhergeht, auch mit dem Anspruch, dass man damit auch alles tun kann, weil man sich nicht im eigentlichen Sinne beschränkt, sondern nur für einen bestimmten Stil entscheidet.
Ich gebe dir da auf jeden Fall recht, dass es so ist. Also gerade im Gegensatz zu Java. Also in Java kann man eigentlich keine Sachen tun, die irgendwie schwer zu verstehen wären, außer gewaltige Bibliotheken mit komplexen Semantiken zu bauen. Aber so die Sprache an sich ist halt an Trivialität kaum zu überbieten. Also es wurde auch, ich weiß nicht, ob ich den schon erzählt hatte, dass Java irgendwie C++-, es ist ja...
Java-Bashing dann in einem anderen Podcast. Ich überlege ja tatsächlich, einen Podcast mit Java zu machen.
Ja, also Java hat sicherlich, also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Vorteil von Java und C++. Es ist tatsächlich das Problem, dass man Dinge schreiben kann in C++, die nicht einfach zu verstehen sind oder gar nicht zu verstehen sind. Aber das hat halt auch was mit dieser, wie gesagt, mit dieser Dahn-Geschichte zu tun. Es ist dann so, was man nicht erwarten kann, dass jemand, der jetzt mit dem dritten oder vierten oder fünften Dahn operiert und eben auf dieser Ebene Code schreibt, dass der von jemandem mit einem gelben oder roten Gürtel irgendwie, also der sieht das zwar, aber der durchblickt das schlichtweg einfach nicht. Aber jemand anderer, der mit ebenfalls auf dem dritten oder vierten Dahn operiert, hat relativ wenig Probleme, so zu verstehen, was dort abgeht. Und da gibt es sogar eine sehr mächtige Kommunikation, die dann stattfindet, wo dann in sehr kompakter Form einfach ganz komplexe Dinge kommuniziert werden können. Und was man auch noch sehen muss, es gibt schon viele Dinge, die man in den Standardbibliotheken macht. Das heißt, in der Standardbibliothek sind halt sehr viele Dinge, sehr viele Muster, Pattern, wie man die Sprache verwendet, die tauchen immer wieder auf. Und wenn man die einmal kennt, so also Iteratoren oder andere Dinge, die jetzt gar nicht so in der Sprache an sich festgelegt sind, sondern die halt mehr auf der Konventionsseite funktionieren. Ich meine, es ist nicht so schlimm wie bei Lisp, wo die in der Sprache... Ich glaube, es geht um die Sprache, die fast gar nichts ist und dann letztendlich über die Libraries wiederum komplett neue Sprachen in Lisp. Also wie zum Beispiel das Formakro ist. In Lisp ist glaube ich eine komplett eigene Programmiersprache für sich. Also in die Richtung geht es teilweise auch in C++. Man muss halt sehen, man kann nicht erwarten, C++ hat eben eine gewisse Tiefe und das heißt, dass es auch, dass selbst nach jetzt bei mir, nach 15 Jahren Arbeiten mit C++ habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt bei der Sprache unbedingt an allzu viele Grenzen stoße, wo ich also ein paar Ecken schon, ich sage, okay, muss das jetzt sein oder hier hätte ich es doch lieber gerne etwas anders, aber ansonsten ist es so, dass die Sprache einfach das tut, was ich tun will und relativ formbar auch unter meinen Händen ist. Ich jederzeit alles irgendwo ranbauen kann und dass ich eben relativ selten gezwungen bin, mich zu wiederholen, sondern halt die gemeinsamen Dinge. Also ich habe sehr viele Möglichkeiten, Gemeinsamkeiten zu abstrahieren und in irgendeiner Form gar nicht so sehr, also nicht unbedingt objektorientiert, sondern da gibt es einen Haufen anderer Möglichkeiten, wie ich halt gemeinsamen Code rausziehen kann und das ist ja, das ist einfach eine befriedigende Art mit einer entsprechenden Tiefe. Ohne und dann noch als letzten Punkt, es gibt einen Test noch für Programmiersprachen, der sehr einfach ist und der aber schon mal Programmiersprachen einfach in verschiedene Gruppen trennt, nämlich in dem Fall ganz einfach ein Microbenchmark, wie schnell kann ich in der Programmiersprache einen Zähler betätigen oder wie viele Funktionsaufrufe kann ich maximal so in einer Sekunde ablaufen lassen. Und da ist es so, dass ich auf aktuellen Prozessoren in C++ einfach zwei bis drei Milliarden Zählschritte durchführen kann. Genauso viel wie in Assembler. Java kommt mit den besten Just-in-Time-Compilern je nachdem Faktor vier langsamer. Bei Java bin ich einfach schon mal, wenn ich das Maximum erreichen will, ist es schon mal 25 Prozent. Und die ganzen dynamischen Sprachen oder Script-Sprachen, die auch ihre Berechtigung haben, wiederum auf einer anderen Ebene, die sind dann Faktor 100, 1000, 10.000, 100.000 langsamer als C++.
Also ich fasse mal zusammen, C++ ist Performance plus man kann alles so machen, wie man es für richtig hält.
Es ist ein Power-Tool für Profis.
Ein Power-Tool für Profis, man braucht aber irgendwie den richtigen Gürtel. Welchen hast du jetzt?
Ich würde sagen, es gibt so etwas wie den neunten Dahn. Ich würde sagen, dass ich mich irgendwo bei den Dahn, vielleicht dritten, vierten, fünften, irgendwo in der Gegend, wenn man jetzt jemanden wie Alexandrescu oder der Guru, der den neunten oder zehnten Dahn hat.
Strostrup auch?
Ja gut, Strostrup ist außerhalb der Wertung. Ich habe vor ein paar Jahren die URLs leider vergessen, die ich raussuche. Es gibt so ein paar C++-Tests, wo man seine Fähigkeiten anhand einem Multiple-Choice-Test.
Ah, dann kriegt man seinen Dahn zugewiesen.
Ja, dann kriegt man Punkte. Dann kann man gucken, in der Region, also nach Region, weltweit und regional, an welchem Ranking man dann so ist. Ich war, als ich das vor einigen Jahren, also vor fünf, sechs Jahren, mal gemacht habe, also Alexandrescu war wirklich ganz oben so, er nahm wirklich die Spitzenposition ein. Also da findet man auch die Gurus, also sie machen auch diese Tests und es ist, also wenn man mal gucken, ob ich noch für die URL dann raussuchen kann. Und ich bin zumindest irgendwie in Deutschland, bin ich unter die Top 10 seiner Zeit, was das Scoring angeht und weltweit unter die Top 100 damals gekommen bei, ich weiß nicht, 20.000, 30.000 Leuten, die den Test gemacht haben, also was auch immer das bedeuten mag.
Also Leute, ihr hört schon, Vorsicht, wenn ihr Pavel in der Straßenbahn begegnet, der hat den dritten Darm. Ich denke, wir schließen das jetzt hier mal ab. Das war ein Versuch, wieder mal eine Pur-Miersprache, nicht so sehr aus ihren einzelnen Features herauszuschreiben, sondern irgendwie aus seinen Wesensaspekten und sonstigen Philosophien. Ob wir da jetzt Erfolg gehabt haben, das sei mal euch überlassen, verbunden mit der immer wieder erholten Aufforderung, Feedback zu geben zu Chaosradio Express, über alle Kanäle, die wir da haben. Da ist einerseits das Blog, blog.chaosradio.ccc.de. Da hat jede CAE-Sendung auch seinen eigenen Eintrag. Oder ihr schreibt eine E-Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Das wird auch alles gelesen und beantwortet. Ja, und ich bedanke mich, Pavel. Und ich sag Tschüss, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!